and now joining us from California early
our ben shapiro author and columnist mr.
shapiro
his most recent book the people vs.
barack obama the criminal case against
the obama administration mr. shapiro
this book just came out do you support
what the house is doing ensuing the
president i do i think that the house
the decision to see the president it's
not the best of all available options
but it is an option in terms of curbing
the president's power and for those who
think that it's over the top now i just
remind them that the last time the house
did this the president of the united
states last night nothing at the Supreme
Court level so the question becomes what
do you do in case of executive overreach
impeachment is obviously a silly option
given the the Democratic control of the
Senate and so they really are left with
two options which is to cut funding for
some of the president's programs which I
believe they should do or to see the
president if he executive overreach is
which is what he's doing and what
they're doing well West Pruden this
morning in the Washington Times talks
about the impeachment issue and he says
the Democrats are using it as a
fundraising tool and that it's not a
viable option then that's that's correct
I mean it's not a viable option given
Democratic control of the Senate even
with Republican control of the Senate
Republicans weren't willing to convict
President Clinton in the Senate when
he'd clearly committed perjury so the
idea that impeachment is ever going to
happen here is ridiculous the truth is
that impeachment as a generalized tool
is ineffective over the course of US
history we've had a grand total of 18
impeachments in the house and nine
actual convictions in the Senate once
every 30 years that's not sufficient to
curb the excesses of the executive
branch in the end the legislative power
is sufficient to curb the excesses of
the executive branch and that's what
needs to be used well Nancy Pelosi
talked about the GOP and the lawsuit I
want to get your reaction to what she
had to say Republicans do not have time
to raise the minimum wage but they have
time to sue the President of the United
States they didn't have money to feed
the children help the American people
but they have they want a blank cheque
to sue the president they've lost moral
standing and what's happening on the
border
and they have no standing ensuing the
president and that sort of the framework
for how they go forward Ben Shapiro well
of course they have standing as far as
the notion that they disagree with Nancy
Pelosi on policy and therefore they
shouldn't pursue any measures against
the president that's exactly what you
would expect Nancy Pelosi to say I mean
that's that's a really kind of
ridiculous and facile comment by Nancy
Pelosi but look it's politically
manipulative and that's what Nancy
Pelosi is very good at I'll give her
that she's very qualified to politically
manipulating the idea that Republicans
somehow have a choice between agreeing
with Nancy Pelosi or suing the president
those are the only two available choices
that's a false dichotomy it's silly
theoretically they could do both but the
bottom line is that when the president
overstepped his boundaries who is going
to stop him and this is I think a really
troubling sort of indictment of what's
going on in in Congress right now the
fact is that there are a lot of people
in the United States not just in
Congress who seemed to have fallen into
the trap of believing that because they
don't like what Republicans in Congress
are doing therefore the president should
get to act on his own well the honest to
goodness that that is the beginnings of
tyranny I mean when you are talking
about the possibility of you know I
forget the I don't remember the exact
provision in the Constitution where it
says that if Congress doesn't do what
the president wants them to do the
president gets to do whatever he wants
that that would be actually tyranny and
and my impression so the Constitution is
not real fond of that and then we
actually fought a revolution to stop
exactly that sort of behavior mr.
Shapiro we were talking with our viewers
earlier this morning about the fact that
the house is staying in session to
potentially work on the border bill what
do you think about that well I mean I
think that the house should stay in
session to work on a border bill I think
the house should also take into account
what a lot of the grassroots things and
and what you're seeing right now is a
real gap between the grassroots and the
establishment on the border bill and
Breitbart news which where I'm editor at
large has been pushing I think pretty
hard against the border bill and I think
with good reason the fact is that John
banners border bill is insufficient it
doesn't curb the president's executive
authority or regulatory ability to give
it amnesty to millions and millions of
people which is of course President
Obama's end goal here and and so I think
the look this is a debate that needs to
be had but the truth is what's so funny
about all of this is that I think that
99% of Americans basically agree on this
shut the border
figure out what to do with the people
here and the fact that we keep going
back to this idea that all legislation
has to be comprehensive and omnibus I've
never understood that it makes no sense
to me I don't understand why an 800-page
bill is better than a two-page bill when
we all know what needs to be done and
doing it in piecemeal fashion would
probably be the best solution Harvard
Law UCLA
editor large at breitbart.com columnist
at truth revolt calm and a radio
talk-show host and an author of five now
six books
his most recent book the People vs
Barack Obama the criminal case against
the Obama administration Ben Shapiro is
our guest and Mike in Westminster
Maryland independent line you're the
first caller go ahead Mike good morning
how you guys doing good
I just you know my comment is basically
you know I feel like you know with all
that we're talking about here even with
a bomb and and now they're gonna stay in
session and try to solve this they're
not going to add anything to it's just
gonna be the same thing as it was with
the health bill we'll have the same
thing with the borders and and it just
seems like to me you know I mean it's
like tricks it for the devil I mean
they've been just this whole thing is
it's just a game that we're not going to
see it's just going to keep destroying
the sovereignty of America and and
that's what we're aiming for I mean we
can sit here every day and people get
them we're all calling and everybody's
talking about what's going on here when
there was stuff and nobody's dealing
with you know Obama and and he should be
he should be he should have been gone by
now
I mean we didn't have any problem with
Nixon but all of a sudden we're just
we're just gonna play this game and then
it's just it's disgusting because it's
like every morning listening to this
it's just it's like the economy's didn't
have any problem standing up you know
against tyranny that was going on and
there was more of a Christian base back
there and I feel that that's you know
that's what we're really at we just
don't have a spiritual malady spin the
story in America and and it's just a
greed that sits upon up there on the
Capitol and all these people that are
making all the laws now don't really
give a crap about the p40 all right
I think we got your point Ben Shapiro I
certainly understand the frustration I
mean what we're watching right now is an
administration that doesn't want to
follow laws that are already on the
books and look this is not the first
administration that's been doing that
the Bush administration was not good on
the border issue either and the idea
that we're gonna pass new laws and that
somehow going to fix everything
when you have an executive branch that
doesn't want to enforce the law as it
currently stands passing new laws
doesn't seem to be the real and proper
solution and for those who say that we
don't have the power to close the border
for example of course we do well it
would cost about 25 billion dollars to
build the border fence along the
southern border sort of like Israel's
southern Israel's border fence and it
would take probably something like
15,000 national guard troops to actually
secure the border and yet we're not
doing any of that and and the fact that
we are we are not doing any of that just
speaks to the fact that we don't want to
deport a lot of the folks who are coming
in and looking on immigration is
actually that I'm for open immigration
in the absence of a welfare state the
problem here is that you can't have both
and what's so astonishing is that you
have both parties sort of arguing for
the for the continuation of an open
border to a certain extent for different
purposes Democrats want an open border
because they think it's going to get
them more voters and a lot of
Republicans want an open border because
they're beholden to the US Chamber of
Commerce and they want cheap labor the
reality is that the people who are
coming here who want to be part of the
American dream the American Dream has to
exist in order for them to be part of it
the American Dream is predicated on the
notion that hard work allows you to get
ahead and that the welfare state is not
going to allow people to basically mooch
off the system and and even if people
are coming here for the right reasons if
they're coming here with no education
and if they're coming here with no
marketable job skills if we have a
welfare state in place then they are
going to be a net burden on the system
unfortunately this is a tweet for you
from living no-limits mr. Shapiro we all
know that going after the president will
sell a lot of books but can you admit
that the house is dysfunctional or
incompetent I certainly think that the
Congress is incompetent I mean I don't
think there's anything new about that
the Congress has the power to to use its
legislative power to check the president
you know the fact that President Obama
is overstepping his constitutional
boundaries is no excuse for the House
abdicating their duty in giving the
executive branch more and more power
which they've done consistently over the
last hundred years there
nothing new about this particular house
mr. Shapiro any difference now with
Kevin McCarthy as Majority Leader do you
have any thoughts about that well I
haven't seen any major difference thus
far I mean I think that McCarthy may be
slightly more in touch with the
grassroots than Eric Cantor was but I
haven't seen any real impact yet
Debbi Columbus Indiana Republican line
please go ahead Debbie hi only thing I
want to tell all the American people is
that we are the boss of the Senate the
Congress the president we voted all
those people in and if we were doing a
job like they're doing right now we as
bosses we walk in and say you're all
fired and therefore what they need to do
is sit down and decide when there's time
to reelect people are we really wanted
going back to this chaos that we're in
right now or do we want to straighten
out this problem and get some new ideals
in there get rid of Pelosi get rid of
John Boehner get rid of all of them get
rid of all of them if they can't work
for American people farm mr. spiro they
kind of throw them all out mentality
again I understand the frustration I
think there's a lot of justification to
it the reality is that the American
people it can't just be we're going to
elect people every two years or every
four years in the case of the President
or every six years in the case of
senators and then we just forget about
it and they're left to their own devices
the fact is that the American people
have to constantly be putting pressure
on their Congress people we're actually
seeing that right now I actually think
that the level of supposed dysfunction
in Washington is is not the worst thing
in the world I'm actually more concerned
when Washington is quote-unquote fully
functional and everybody agrees on doing
things that undermine Americans right so
I'd rather have Congress do nothing than
have Congress do something that's the
wrong thing Ben Shapiro want to get your
reaction to John Boehner talking about
impeachment coming from the president's
own staff and coming from Democrats on
Capitol Hill why because they're trying
to rally their people to give money and
to show up in this year's election we
have no plans to impeach the president
we have no future plan
listen it's ball a scam started by
Democrats at the White House ben shapiro
i think there's some truth that i think
i think the fact that the white house
wants to talk about impeachment all the
time is good evidence that they're
interested in using it for political
gain i think that look the president is
guilty of impeachable offenses does that
mean that he should be impeached
politically of course not Nancy Pelosi
had the right response to this question
when she was asked this question back in
2005 or 2006 she said yes Bush is guilty
of impeachable offenses but we can't
impeach you okay that's the right answer
that's actually true for for President
Obama and I think that it's important to
recognize that even though the president
may have committed impeachable offenses
there are political realities to deal
with and the only way to really stop
executive branch overreaches is not even
to impeach President Obama because
here's the truth and I know people think
on the right for some reason that moving
President Obama out of office would be
some sort of political panacea it would
not be Joe Biden would simply take over
you have an executive branch there's
three million people strong you have
regulatory agencies armed to the teeth
in every area of American life and
changing who occupies the Oval Office is
not going to change any of that this is
going to take a significantly more
prolonged and and determined effort in
order to minimize and shrink the size
and scope of governments that it's not
as oppressive and burdensome as it is in
your life right now and that does not
change just by getting rid of one guy in
the Oval Office well ben shapiro how do
you sell that message to a majority of
americans well i think that message is
being sold to a majority of americans as
government becomes more oppressive i
think that government is the best
salesman for its own incompetence and
what we're watching right now is that
everyday government is is encroaching
more and more upon the personal space of
americans and more and more Americans
are beginning to buck that you're seeing
resistance at the state level from
various governors including Jan Brewer
and Rick Perry you're seeing various
forms of resistance at the individual
level where individuals are simply
refusing to abide by what they believe
to be incompetent or wrong federal
regulations I think that the government
is doing a pretty good job of convincing
people it's really bad at a lot of stuff
Robert is calling in from Leesville
South Carolina on our Democrats line
Robert you're on yes still wondering how
they don't recognize who God is because
they're not there on their own God put
this president in office
we when they said that he'll be a
one-term I say I think they are I have
my father made sure that he was gonna be
two-term and I'm just really upset with
the whole process it's just something in
a sense anymore how they keep coming
after this one president because he is
black Ben Shapiro we hear that often
hear from callers on the Washington
journal that Republicans are attacking
the president because he's
african-american and that no president
has faced this kind of harshness before
I mean it's ridiculous George W Bush
faced documentaries about why you should
be assassinated so I highly doubt and
people have very very short memories the
idea that opposition to Barack Obama is
in any way unique is ridiculous and the
idea that it's based on race is also
ridiculous there's their strong
opposition of this president because he
has been exactly what he promised to be
a transformative president he's
completely transformed the health care
system which is one-sixth of the United
States economy he has completely flipped
the United States on foreign policy his
border policy has been a ground shift I
mean it's been an acceleration of what
we've seen over the last 20 years from
both parties this president is quite
extreme and that that's why you're
seeing so much resistance to the
President of the United States and I do
have to say this the idolatrous worship
for this president in some precincts of
the United States is significantly more
frightening than anything the President
himself is doing when David Horowitz
introduced you the other night
before your book talk he said that the
president was a lifelong communist do
you agree with that no I mean I think
that the president is is a political
nihilist at this point as far as whether
he's a lifelong communist or not the
fact is that he studied with Frank
Marshall Davis it was a lifelong
communist I think that the president has
a lot of sympathies toward a Marxist a
point of view as far as the idea that he
wants to nationalize all industry it
depends on what your definition of
communism is not to be Clintonian in
this but I think that when people think
communism they think Soviet Union I
don't think that Soviet Union is Barack
Obama's goal I think that a leveling of
the economic playing field and what I
mean by that is a leveling of economic
outcomes is his goal so I do I think I
think he's a Marxist without being a
communist if that makes some sense
Frank is calling in from New Castle
Pennsylvania independent line go ahead
Frank yes
mr. Shapiro if he thinks this is just a
big act on both sides two Democrats and
Republicans because they both have
things to gain from this the Democrats
think they're going to gain themselves
blue states out of red states and
Republicans and the controlled by the
industries and the big-money businesses
in this country want a third-world work
force in this country and I would like
to hear his comments on that thank I
mean on the immigration issue I think I
certainly think there is truth to the
idea that both parties are in favor of
immigration policy that is not good for
the United States I think that a lot of
politicians who are beholden to big
business in the Republican Party and who
believe that by importing a cheap labor
force they're somehow helping the
situation and I think there are a lot of
Democrats who want to keep that border
open for a couple of reasons the first
is that they believe that eventually all
these people will vote the second is
that they believe the Hispanics
currently in the United States will vote
for them if they're soft on border
policy and the third reason that they
are for an open border is because in the
end they understand that we're going to
have to pay for a lot of the folks
crossing the border and there is as I
said a sort of nihilistic streak within
the current Democratic Party that
suggests that tearing down people who
are wealthy is more important than
building up people who are poor and so
if there are more people who are on the
public dole that's actually a manifestly
good thing because that is a requirement
now for rich people to pay higher taxes
and that in and of itself is moral good
bench pero Joe Lieberman has an op-ed
this morning in the Wall Street Journal
not sure if you've had a chance to see
it this early in California just not yet
read a little section get your response
that the headline is leaving US allies
adrift as chaos Rises the actions of the
US in response to the current war
between Israel our closest ally in the
region and Hamas a violent extremist
organization have further divided us
from our allies the Obama administration
has rightly supported Israel's right to
defend itself against Hamas as missiles
and terrorist attacks but the
administration's recent efforts to
broker a ceasefire sent an unsettling
message the White House seemed to be
siding with Qatar and Turkey supporters
of Hamas and against not just Israel but
also Egypt Saudi Arabia Jordan UAE and
Palestinian Authority well clearly he's
right I mean that's a dramatic
understatement of the situation the
president has actually reversed sides in
the war on terror we're now a lying
ourselves with the Muslim Brotherhood
we're now a lying ourselves with Hamas
we just sent them forty seven million
dollars in aid and we've been spending
four hundred million dollars a year on a
Palestinian unity government that
includes the terrorist group Hamas when
it we've been we've been brokering deals
with Iran that are that are less than
less than worthless and have put Israel
in the position of having to strike
against you against the US as stated
policy if his real wishes to defend
herself
what we're watching right now is is
either a manifestation as I've said many
times of Jew hatred on the part of the
Obama administration in specific dislike
of Israel or a more generalized dislike
of American allies which is also a
possibility given the USS abandonment of
its allies in Ukraine as well as its
allies in Poland as well as its allies
in places like Taiwan what we're
watching right now is a shrinking of the
American influence on the world scene
and President Obama seems to be very
much in favor of that Chris gaithersburg
maryland republican good morning you're
on with ben shapiro good morning thank
you for taking my call and thank you for
c-span's a few questions I had for you
was one do you believe that the
Republicans are sitting back and just
letting this guy do as much damage
meaning the President as you know try to
keep his reins in a little bit second of
all do you think he'll go down in
history as one of the bottom five
presidents even with the rewriting of
history books which I'm sure will be
done and I always feel like the
Democrats their last argument is always
racism I'll take my communist fare thank
you well I mean I think that they're
they're a couple of different questions
there as far as President Obama's place
in history I think the President Obama's
place in history will have to be decided
by whichever historians are writing I
mean Howard Zinn thinks that LBJ was a
wonderful president a lot of Americans
think LBJ was terrible presidents that
depends on which historian is actually
talking I'm not a big fan of the
quote/unquote judgments of history
because I don't think there's a unified
stream in the judgment of history I
don't think that history is God or
morality and I don't think that it's a
unified stream I think there are many
different historians of many different
perspectives most of them wrong so
there's that as far as whether the the
Wiccans have been enabling the President
of the United States that I very much
doubt I do not think that the Republican
Congress has enabled the President of
the United States the fact is that since
2010 the president's major initiatives
have failed at every legislative level
which is why he is now resorting to
dramatic overages in terms of executive
authority and as far as the racism
argument clearly that's true but it's
not a last resort it's a first resort
for folks on the Left every time if
somebody disagrees with the President of
the United States or the Attorney
General of the United States or anybody
in this administration who happens to be
black the first resort of the left is to
start shouting about how its racism as
opposed to possible extremism of the
people in power ben shapiro where can
people hear your radio show i have two
radio shows actually so the first one is
a group radio show it's me a liberal guy
and another conservative in the mornings
on care la 870 in Los Angeles and then I
have a second radio show 3:00 to 6:00 in
the afternoon Pacific time on Katie th
770 in Seattle and are those available
on the internet as well yes Carol a 870
dot-com for the morning show which is
six to nine Pacific and then the the
Katie th show is Katie th com
Governor Christie stumps in New
Hampshire's the headline in the Wall
Street Journal what's your take on the
2016 Republican field mr. Shapiro
it's an open field it's a very open
field I think that you're going to see
the establishment consolidate around
someone chris Christie seems to have
lost some of his luster for a lot of the
establishment folks there's a lot of
talk behind the scenes about Jeb Bush
which i think is unfortunate I don't
think that a bush clinton election is
going to go well for republicans it
didn't the last time there there a
number of candidates who are out there
for I don't think of have seen the
spotlight yet who I think will do some
damage before all this is said and done
I think Bobby Jindal will do some damage
before this is done I think Mike Pence
from Indiana is going to run I think
that he will he will do some damage
before this is done but the truth is
that the field is so open at this point
and and for some reason the American
people are so in love with stealth
candidates at this point there really is
the possibility of an outsider that
somebody that we've never really
considered jumping into the race and
really shaking things up so it's it's
it's still very early and I know that
that's a cop-out but unfortunately it is
really early and then so I'm gonna have
to sort of cop out on that one Greg
Indianapolis Democrat good
morning yes good morning it's so funny
listening that you because the thing is
the funny thing is I can guarantee you
probably next 20 years maybe I still be
around here there's gonna be a Latino
president or something just like there's
an african-american president and I
think that you white folks are just
getting scared and you panicking and so
that's why you go against Obama for
everything that he said and everything
he does because the white folks the
white folks is losing their power Thank
You Ben Shapiro you see this thing this
is called yarmulke okay there's this
idea that that all white folk are the
same and that we all have the same
beliefs and the idea that the white folk
are simply afraid of losing their power
first well I'm not sure one exactly my
folk Jewish people became white people I
guess that was when we became successful
in the United States but the idea that
we keep hearing over and over and over
that white folks are just afraid of
losing their supposed supremacy in
American society is asinine insulting
ridiculous and every other derogatory
word that I can think of the fact is
that there are people who are upset in
this country of every race about what's
happening to the country and if you're
not upset about what's happening in the
country you are not looking closely
enough about 15 minutes left with our
guests this morning David is in Lawton
Oklahoma hi David I thanks for taking my
call
first-time caller I was just calling to
comment on Obama's leadership and the
previous caller that said that brought a
brace and brought up in being African
American and and just disrespecting the
guests and calling them you know white
and just categorized and white as all
I'm Native American
I'm from the Pima tribes and Mojave
tribes and I'm I'm very very upset with
what Obama's doing with this country
he's taking this country into into a
country without a border and if you
don't have a border then you're not even
a country so I do feel that he should be
impeached
I mean if me being a Native American and
if I was president you better believe
you guys would impeach me in a heartbeat
for what I'm doing for it's called what
Obama's doing so I
see the race continually put up for just
in giving them a pass just because he's
african-american whatever I mean we
don't even know who his real father is I
mean they say Barack Obama from Africa
but I mean I saw a documentary about
that it was it was a this guy Davis was
his father so who is who is it who is
the guy who's in the White House in the
first place so I just my comment is he's
terrible leadership he should be
impeached
I wish the American people will wake up
and and realize that he's distorter
country he's trying to all right do you
think we got the point
Ben Shapiro you know clouding the the
Obama administration with conspiracy
theories about his parentage I think is
not only mistaken but silly the fact is
that we know who his father is we know
where he was born all the rest of this
is is is nonsense as far as the notion
that he does have a certain luster
because of his race I think that in the
eyes of the media that's certainly true
I think that that if we had seen another
president perform the way that this
president has performed I think the
media would have at least turned a
little bit on him a long time ago what
we're watching right now at least in
certain segments of the American
population is a worship for this
president the the likes of which I have
not seen certainly in my lifetime that
the fact that his approval rating
despite his performance has never
dropped significantly below 40 percent
demonstrates a certain level of loyalty
to him that cannot be explained by
certainly his political success bench
parry your radio show comes on in about
45 minutes from now what's your lead
well we'll certainly be talking about
the immigration issue and the debate
that's happening over immigration we'll
certainly be talking about Israel and
the continuing fallout in in the Gaza
Strip and and I hope that we'll be
talking about the California water
drought which continues to be ridiculous
given that the the governor of our state
is about to start finding us on an
individual level essentially well we
just blew 20 million gallons of water in
a main break over at UCLA and you see
the students swimming around like it's
like it's the pool over a poly how
serious is that water shortage or that
drought right now that's a serious water
shortage there's no question but this
just demonstrates what happens when you
have a government that has subsidized
water rates I mean the fact is that what
they're doing right now is they're
fining people for
overuse of water but they're keeping the
water rates so low that people have an
incentive to keep using water at these
rates plus the in just a little known
fact here that the reality is that the
government of California is losing 10%
of its water in leaks
they're not even fixing those leaks
instead they are finding individuals
which demonstrates whenever government
makes a mistake you pay two times
Teresa Carnegie Pennsylvania on our
Republican line Ben Shapiro is our guest
you hide man I'm 82 have been boater all
my life
I am so disgusted with our government
the way that it's being run they're like
height kindergarten kids
I'm gonna take my marbles and go home
they can't settle anything our poor
veterans for God's sakes that have
protected them while they're snug as
bugs in their bed and their families and
they they're crucifying them without
their benefits shame shame they had a
lock the doors on them and they come
back from I don't know how many recesses
this is they want to get to the borders
that's fine but you know they've got cut
the unemployment rates on people that
are in their fifties that you know fault
of their own or lost their job they
can't get another one and yet they want
billions for the borders to a lot of
criminals walk in here shame shame we
need to do something I I can't just
blame Obama I'm a registered Democrat
since I got I did not vote at this this
time around this country is downsizing
fast in it's a shame I had sleep members
of my family fight all three wars and
we're proud to do it for the country you
wouldn't find kids today that wanna
enlist is sick of it thank you very much
Ben Shapiro we need to restore
accountability to our to our government
and the way that you do that is by
dramatically slashing the executive
branch the fact is that if you don't
like what the government is doing right
now you can change your congressperson
but you can't change many of the folks
over at the regulatory agencies and
Congress has an interest in pushing all
authority over to those regulatory
agencies specifically so that they can
just keep being reelected the fact is
this if you want an answerable
government the
native branch must be shrunk and that
way if you don't like your Congressman
you can get rid of your congressman and
it'll actually have consequences right
now not only are we not getting rid of
our Congress people even if we do get
rid of our Congress people there is no
major change in how the country is
administered so we should all be very
smaller and more control of the
government one that's under our control
not our little control of one man at the
top of the federal branch which is not
even accurate or at the control of
people who are unelected and put there
long ago in regulatory bodies and will
never lose their jobs no matter what
criminal activities they engage with
mattel criminal activities in which they
engage Ben Shapiro do you consider
yourself a tea party right absolutely
absolutely because I think the tea party
has been dramatically missed defined by
the media it's very similar standard
percent of Americans aren't quote
unquote Tea Partiers what it means to be
a tea partiers that you are for a
smaller government and lower taxes I
don't understand anybody at this point
in American life who's for a bigger
government and higher taxes Anthony in
Stockton California Democrats line go
ahead with your question or comment for
Ben Shapiro yes thank you for taking my
call first of all I want to say Ben
Shapiro he's from California as well
represent California but I want to
comment he made the comment about Jerry
Brown and the bottom line on that is
that we had a Republican governor and he
destroyed Gallup whiteness worsening and
no one said anything and then Jerry
Brown gets in there and we're in the
black instead of being in the rear so
he's been doing a wonderful job so they
need to give credit where credit is due
also talking about the president you
know this immigration everybody here is
if it's an immigrant and it's
hypocritical for being and all the
Republican parties to sit up there and
and talk about these children that
coming over the border or whatever and
they came over their ancestors came over
the border if you want to be keep it
real and be real about it leave the
country and give it back to the Native
American the Indians do right who
rightfully belong to and I get tired of
hearing all this this talk about
immigrants imminent they're taking our
country well guess what America
all right Anthony thank you sir Ben
Shapiro well they're two issues there
one is jerry brown's governance arnold
schwarzenegger was a horror show of a
government governor in California Jerry
Brown has arithmetic aliy multiplied the
budget the idea that he's in the black
is asinine he's not in the black he's in
the black for one year and that's
because he dramatically raised taxes on
the people in California and we have
budget deficits from here as far as the
eye can see we have over a trillion
dollars in structural debt here in the
state of California so the idea that
Jerry Brown has healed all wounds is a
fiction created by the LA Times as far
as the idea that we are all emigrants of
course we are which is why if he had
watched earlier in the program he would
have seen me say then I am for pretty
much an open border if we get rid of the
welfare state the problem is you cannot
have a welfare state and an open border
it's like having a doughnut shop and
giving away free doughnuts to everybody
who walks in if you do that you will
soon be out of doughnuts and that's
exactly what's happening in the United
States what does bother me is these the
component and I think that this is what
the Democratic Party plays on the ethnic
and racial solidarity component this
idea that well it's just all these white
folks who want to shut down all these
black folks and Hispanic folks from
coming in the country first of all there
are a lot of black folks we're not
particularly happy with the border
situation a lot of Hispanic folks who
are not particularly happy with the
border situation
well it I fail to understand how being
in favor of a rationally regulated
border and understanding who comes in
the country is in any way detrimental to
the United States and I fail to
understand how taking the position that
anybody who wants to be part of the
American Dream should be part of the
American dream so long as they are not
on public benefits is in any way
anti-immigrant here's a headline just
out ceasefire collapses between Israel
and Hamas it looks like less than three
hours after a three-day humanitarian
ceasefire the truce broke down when
clashes began and militants fired
rockets into Israel any comment mr.
Shapiro
shocker I mean shocker turns out the
Kumasi has a stated goal of destroying
Israel and murdering every Jew in the
region it doesn't want to ceasefire well
there's there's a huge shock to the
Obama administration's ridiculous
position that Israel should suddenly
declare a humanitarian ceasefire and
they should stop going after people who
want to murder them in their beds it
just demonstrates again the blindness of
this administration it demonstrates the
the moral incapacity of the world to
in true evil and what we are watching
with Hamas and Israel is as clear a case
of good versus evil as you can see in
the modern world today ben shapiro
appeared on book tv's in-depth program
last september three hours talking about
his several books you can watch that at
book TV org we also just covered his
most recent book the People vs Barack
Obama the criminal case against the
Obama administration that - you can
watch online at book tv.org a couple of
tweets here James art says I'll have a
little more spring in my conservative
step this morning thanks to the
no-holds-barred attitude of ben shapiro
and sea dog asks week ensued the
president for overstepping his authority
why not sue congress for not doing their
job well yeah i think that the proper
remedy for congress is to just not elect
them they're up every two years so we
can do that as as far as Congress's
structural problems i think that we need
to get away from this idea unfortunately
that it's become very common in america
that compromise in the legislation or
the job of congress no the job of
Congress is to protect your rights
that's the job of Congress and if
they're compromising on your rights
that's not a compromise that you want to
be part of and if they are creating
legislation that violates those rights
that's not something you want to be part
of either what we want is a Congress
that is answerable to us and we want an
executive body that is answerable to us
what we're watching is a gradual slide
into executive dictatorship because we
have a group of people in America who
don't watch closely and and yell for
compromise and then yell for something
to be done whenever there's a problem
whenever there's a crisis something must
be done and if Congress won't do it then
the President of the United States
should well as it turns out in the in
the Constitution of the United States
the job of the president is pretty
specifically defined and nowhere in
there does it say do good stuff that is
not the job of the president the job of
the president is to adhere to his
constitutional boundaries and when we
lost that we lost the system Gloria
Sheridan Wyoming on our independent line
Ben Shapiro is our guest yes I just you
know have one question in one comment
the you know mr. Shapiro mentioned that
you know while Obama could have an
impeachable offenses that they wouldn't
impeach him and I just you know like to
ask you know if we're not going to
enforce our laws on the border you know
and let illegals overrun us there
and say oh well you know no biggie
they're just coming in we'll just keep
them and then if you don't you know
impeach the president for wrongdoing you
know what kind of message are we sending
I mean isn't don't we need
accountability somewhere and you know
more than a slap on the wrist and say oh
gee you know we're sorry that you're
doing this you know but you go out and
go right ahead and do it you know we
won't take any action against you you
know and I personally think he should be
impeached and then as far as the
gentleman that called in and was ranting
and raving is a number of them have
about the immigrants yes we're and you
know we're a nation of immigrants but
the point is it's legal immigration you
know they used to come through Ellis
Island and they had medical checks and
we're quarantined if they you know had a
disease or something and they had
paperwork and that they didn't just you
know walk across the border as they
chose and then you know said okay you
know stay here you know we got people
that are doing it legally but you know
you're breaking the law coming across
our borders and you know we'll just bump
you to the head of the line because
you're cheap labor or whatever the thing
you know so I'd like to hear mr.
Shapiro's thoughts on those things and
thank you as far as the immigration
issue and and you know when people's
ancestors came over my great-grandfather
came here in 1921 and the system was
very different you actually had a system
that screened for disease and
criminality and of course that needs to
bed that's for of any country you have
to be able to screen people for disease
criminality and other things that could
affect the general public but the big
difference was that when my
great-grandfather came here there was no
welfare state upon which for him to rely
the idea was that he would come here he
came here with no money he didn't speak
the language he made something of
himself he started a business he made
some money and that's what the American
dream was he didn't come here and and
rely on public benefits unfortunately
right now even if you come here and you
want to do what my great-grandfather did
you're going to be sucked into the maw
of public benefits and that's the way it
is for Americans who are born here I've
said many times that I would trade a
hundred million people who are coming
across the southern border really for
100 million people who are born here
domestically as long as the people who
want to come across the border our
people who actually want to work and not
rely on public benefits and we changed
the system so that they have to work and
can't rely on public benefits and that's
true of the people here as well the big
problem here is the welfare state not
really the border as far as the notion
of impeachment I'm for anything that
stops executive overreach impeachment is
not going to a stop executive overreach
because the Senate is not going to vote
for the impeachment or the conviction of
the President of the United States for
high crimes and misdemeanors and even if
it did it would not stop the executive
overreach the executive branch is too
big it is too burdensome and the only
way we're ever going to stop all of this
is by electing a congress that slices
and I mean with a machete slices the
size and scope of executive authority
Craig McKinney tweets into you what is
your opinion on gay marriage and
abortion so here's my opinion on gay
marriage my belief is that with regard
to gay marriage I'm I'm a a traditional
marriage guy however it's time for the
state to get out of the business of
marriage entirely I don't understand
what the state has to do with marriage I
think it's a mistake for the state to be
involved in marriage marriage is a
relationship between two people I have
two marriage agreements I have my
agreement with the state which I don't
care about and then I have the agreement
my religious marriage agreement with my
wife my ketubah and that's the one that
I actually care about and and that's the
way that I believe that it should be for
most Americans the idea that the
government was ever going to former
traditional marriage by giving tax
benefits to married couples it obviously
didn't work and now they get a tax
penalty for being married I highly doubt
people are getting married specifically
for the tax penalty so the answer for
religious people okay and I'm a
religious person who believes in
traditional marriage here is the danger
if you leave the state in charge of
marriage as an overall matter what
you're going to get is the state green
lighting green lighting gay marriage and
then using gay marriage as a club
against every religious organization in
your state they're gonna start removing
nonprofit statuses from churches for not
performing gay marriages and then once
they are in the private sector not in
the not in the nonprofit sector once
they're in the for-profit sector or the
LLC sector or the corporate sector then
they're going to be shut down if they
refuse to perform gay marriages
religious religious exclusions mean
nothing to folks in the Democratic Party
religious exclusions mean nothing to the
left that is the end goal here the only
way to stop that is to get government
out of the business of marriage entirely
as far as abortion it's protected that
it's it's it's in my belief taking of
human life and not just in my belief in
the beliefs of science it is the taking
of potential or current human life and
that of course does fall under the
purview of government because the only
function of government is to protect
life liberty or property that is
protecting life and whether that life
exists in a woman's uterus or exists
outside of a woman's uterus is
irrelevant to the status of their life
Frances Atwater California Democrat
you're on with author and columnist Ben
Shapiro okay this young man here is
exactly a very a picture of what the
modern Tea Party is like the problem is
they want their government to shrink and
yet on the other hand they also want the
government to get into people's lives
and tell them that they can't do this
and they can't do that they and the
thing is the government is shrunk pretty
far that's the problem when you don't
have one single one single entity for
everyone to gather around and make their
agreements about which is what our
representatives and our senators postal
centers are supposed to do then we don't
we're not supposed to vote them in to
argue with everybody about every little
thing they have going we're voting them
in now on who can hate who's the worst
and that is absolutely absolutely awful
your experience with every word you say
don't you know that mr. spiro I'm
unaware of anything that I've said that
that has even remotely implied a hatred
of anybody I disagree with the policies
of people on the other side I may hate
their policies but I don't hate them and
as far as the notion that got that
Congress that government was not created
for conflict perhaps the caller should
read the Federalist Papers which is
entirely about how interest is supposed
to counterbalance interest this is the
entire goal of the federal government
actually is to have interest
counterbalance interest because a
smaller government preserves our rights
as for the notion that I want to get
into people's lives I'm unaware of any
area of American life where I'm
suggesting that the government get more
involved in people's lives I'm for
decriminalization of marijuana for
example I've just said I don't think the
government should be involved in the
business of marriage
want the government smaller in every
area of American life except for
protection of life liberty and property
and it is that simple and that's why for
example I don't believe that laws with
regard to abortion have anything to do
with violations of Liberty I don't
believe you have the Liberty to murder
another human being or another potential
human being
last call for our guest is Vita in San
Leandro California Republican hi good
morning um I have a couple questions for
the gentleman there my question to you
is when you talk about government the
role of government and what Senators and
Representatives supposed to do you don't
have the knowledge of what the Civic the
roles of what a signature supposed to do
and what a president's supposed to do in
the terms of what their duties are and
the roles are you're giving this
information I am a Republican and the
President does have executive duties
that he supposed they'll carry out and
when it comes to immigration there's a
underneath the 2008 issue that Bush find
he has President Barack Obama has to act
upon that act upon it if he doesn't act
upon it he's violating the Constitution
and so the Republicans don't give him
the authority to to carry it out then
he's violating it so you can't call them
on one thing and then call him on the
other you can that you can't have it
both ways and then veto I think we got
the point
mr. Shapiro as far as the 2008 law that
she's talking about the William
Wilberforce Act I believe the
Republicans have called for changing the
law originally President Obama called
for changing that law to until he
reversed himself and decided that he
actually liked the law because he kept a
lot of these illegal immigrants here
longer the idea that the President of
the United States has unlimited
authority under the Constitution which
seems to be the suggestion is is
ridiculous will the president's
authority extends as far as the
Constitution grants and the Constitution
does not grant the president the
authority to pick which laws he chooses
to enforce which is exactly what we've
seen over and over from this president
as the executive branch might imply
given its name
the executive branches for executing the
laws not for choosing which laws it
feels like executing today or does not
feel like executing tomorrow the essence
of tyranny is the idea that you have one
man at the top of government deciding
which laws are worthy of execution of
which laws are not worthy of execution
Ben Shapiro editor at large Breitbart
columnist at truth revolt calm radio
talk-show host Katie th and kr la author
of six books the most recent the People
vs Barack Obama the criminal case
against the Obama administration thanks
for joining us very early in the morning
in California sir thanks so much I
appreciate it delegate Eleanor Holmes
Norton is next